very few have the ability to watch this
game in person when you get inside of
paxton's finish to the season last year
alex he was outstanding for the yankees
he was and this is a big start for mr
paxton today something to watch tonight
is velocity weighed down lacked command
in his last start and he's a free agent
at the end of the year there's rafael
devers now who has endured a one for
seven start to the series one two to
everest is swung out and missed and
paxton has his first strike out of the
game
so now an rbi opportunity for xander
bogarts who you could fairly say is
really the only red sox hitter to have
enjoyed the series so far bogart's with
a drive out to right field judge is back
on it and that one's gone
sander bogarts with a two run homer into
the first roll of the seats and the red
sox lead at two nothing now paul kept
flying up up and away it carried very
well and boston has the lead two spot
here in the first inning xander's second
homer he has eight rbis
they will take their swings against an
opener for the boston red sox 28 year
old austin bryce makes his first opening
start
he does strike out le mayhew and there's
one gone here's glebe torres has really
emerged the pitch swinging a miss at a
high fast ball so the yanks no contact
but they've got the bases loaded
and a chance for luke voight
here's the pitch swing and a miss he got
him and that retires the side the
yankees load the bases without a hit but
leave them loaded so one out one on for
the number nine hitter tonight miguel
and duhar
a shock to third and a great play by
devers to second for one not in time for
the double play but what a play by rafi
devers on an absolute rocket we now have
two men on with two out so aaron judge
gets a crack here oh
my goodness aaron judge has done it
again
homer's in five straight
santa maria
adios amigo
five home runs in five straight games
aaron judge just plants one into the
left field seats a line shot
and the yankees take the lead three to
two as aaron judge is as hot as you can
be three to three
one out one on it's devers at first
[Applause]
that's a smash into left field another
base hit
and a kick by and duhar
devers coming around to score and boston
goes back in front and as soon as the
yankees had grabbed the lead boston
takes it right back for christian
vasquez now says vasquez lines one into
right field that's a base hit that will
score bogarts and it's 5-3 red sun
beautiful piece of hitting for vasquez
so now the two-time all-star gary
sanchez who was caught looking at strike
three in the second lined out toward
right
martinez will not get it the ball
bounces up against the wall
they're going to wave stanton here comes
the throw to the plate here comes
anthony safe
and gary sanchez with an rbi double into
the right field corner and now giovanni
orchella who hit a grand slam yesterday
burchella with a drive into the left
field corner
o2 breaking ball that he was all over
and that scores sanchez to tie it at
five a piece i mean you just can't get
any hotter than geo or shella is right
now here's andrew bogart who hit a two
run homer in the first inning bringing a
high fly left field left center here
dave back by the bullpen and this ball
is gone
he hit the back wall in the red sox
bullpen and boston leads it six to five
have a multiple home run game for xander
bogart who's three for three
two men are down for luke voight
oh luke voight
into the corner
and gone
so luke voigt ties the ball game up at
six and here comes yankee power again
they're averaging two home runs a game
and we're already in two here tonight
pilar has doubled in three trips to the
plate tonight
judge makes a great shoestring catch in
right judge doing it all on both sides
of the ball six foot seven dave winfield
like out there in right field i sort of
feel like raphael's about to load i do
too
swinging a high drive in a deep right
center field forget about it way gone
into the upper deck of the bleachers
endeavors does have his first home run
and it's seven
six red sox
well here we go with dj levanthu and
we'll see if he can keep another ending
alive for judge here in the eighth
barnes checks it and deal and here it is
up the middle base hit to center field
talkman rounds third he'll score dj le
mayhew spins the tune to tie the game at
seven apiece oh that dj le mayhew just
when you need him guys a machine judge
has a home run in the ball game his
fifth in five
games to left he did it again
oh is he hot his second home run of the
night aaron judges guilty
of putting the yankees into the lead
with his second home run of the night a
bomb into the night
it is nine to seven new york zach
britton looking to hammer down a save
tonight
[Applause]
first pitch grounded to second base
aaron judge is the hero
in a 9-7 yankee victory